we have a disappointing update on the
new Babylon 5 reimagining welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
as I've told you a few times now we are
getting this Babylon 5 reimagining and
the original Creator J Michael
schizinski has been on Twitter once
again he's given us an update and it's
not the best news unfortunately the
project is currently on hold
but why it's on hold is particularly
disappointing now as you guys know if
you are regular sidetrackers I've been
telling you about how Warner Brothers
have been having conversations with
James gear about where Babylon 5 should
end up now I've told you that actually
it's probably not going to end up on the
CW even though that is possible because
they do have first dibs that there was
some conversations about it being on HBO
Max or Max or whatever the hell it's
called this week
and I've also told you that Apple TV
plus were also interested in maybe
buying the project the Apple have a
really good working relationship with
Warner Brothers already they co-produce
um Ted lasso for example and that
actually Apple would love to take
Babylon 5 on and with them being really
the only cash Rich streaming service
going at the moment they're probably one
of the few customers that can actually
afford to do this show Justice but why
is it on hold again for the second third
fourth time so if you don't know what's
going on in Hollywood at the moment
it's difficult if you're British you're
used to everybody going on strike at the
moment but I don't know what that's like
in the United States except the Writers
Guild of America the wga is threatening
to go on strike they have done this
before back in 2007 to 2008 the strike
actually lasted for nearly four months
this actually caused a massive surge in
reality television or the scourge of
television as I like to call it we ended
up getting things like the bloody
Apprentice rather than stuff that was
actually written and thought through it
is fair to say we do not want another
right to strike but we are on the
absolute precipice
first of May in a couple of days is
actually the deadline now we have been
told in the last couple of days that the
wga have had a proposal from this is a
bit of a mouthful the alliance of Motion
Pictures and television producers
let's just call them the alliance
because it sounds evil and I think in
this situation they possibly are the
evil ones for legal purposes are saying
allegedly the alliance has given their
final proposal over to the writer's
Guild and the writer's Guild have
actually sent a counter proposal
but it should be said that the wga is
ready to strike they've already sent out
all the information to their members on
how to do it and what the rules for the
strike are and as I said this has
happened before last time it was over
basically the internet there's a big
disagreement over what at the time they
called New Media it was content that was
written on emerging digital Tech they
call it basically streaming services is
the internet Youtube and blah blah blah
now the wga really held on and were
completely victorious in that strike
they know at the end of the day that
Hollywood is crippled without them they
are literally the start of every project
without the writers there is no movie
there is no television series except for
reality TV which I think we can all
agree is it really television let's just
pretend it doesn't exist maybe that's
just me so the WG I know they've got
this Alliance by the short and curlies
and they are ready to squeeze now I hope
there is no strike because it really
does cause lots of problems for big
projects we're looking forward to I'm
going to talk on Sunday live about
another project that this potential
strike is actually holding up
but
why is it holding up Babylon 5
and why is it basically meant that the
project is currently on hold
well obviously J Michael zazinski will
actually be writing the series but he
does have to put his pen down because he
is a member of the writer's Guild it
would be very very difficult for him to
actually produce any written material
while he is technically on strike he
needs to show an element of solidarity
Warner Brothers have really now got to
throw all of their eggs into their
current baskets as it were I'm not sure
that's the same but we'll run with it
they have to really concentrate on the
project so they're already up and
running they have to get those past the
written stage they have to get the
scripts Etc and everything done so that
they can move forwards with those during
the possible strike if they can get
enough of the written word done they can
still move forwards and at the end of
the day the studios won't have to
actually close so lots of other projects
that we are desperately looking forward
to are being put on the back burner
there just doesn't look until we know
what's going on with the wga we can't
afford to take our eye off what's
already in production we can't afford to
start something new so JMS is waiting
again
now I actually think this project is
still a very distinct possibility I
actually know there are a couple of
companies as I said earlier lining up to
potentially buy it we have something new
and exciting coming out that JMS has
already tweeted about and teased a
little bit now I actually know what this
is but I can't say but I can tell you
guys you're gonna be excited about it it
is going to generate a fair bit of
interest for the Babylon 5 fans and
hopefully maybe a few new ones and maybe
just give the executives that little bit
of a push they need to make sure they
don't forget about the Babylon Fiverr
imagine it now there is a dark cloud
however with this potential strike I've
heard several Whispers over the last
couple of months that a lot of writers
actually believe that the producers this
evil Alliance allegedly for legal
purposes
want the strike that they actually want
this to happen because they want to use
it as an excuse to cancel lots of
projects they want to decrease budgets
and again they can use this as an excuse
to do that as well streaming services in
particular are struggling right now they
desperately need to cut costs but they
want to do it while still saving face on
one way to do that is blame the writers
now actually this has also been reported
in deadline and Hollywood Reporter and a
couple of other places but I've actually
spoken to a couple of writers that are
working in Hollywood today and they
genuinely believe this is the strategy
from the alliance now I genuinely
struggle to believe it because you know
the writers are their bread and butter
they are the foundation that everything
is built off and if the alliance is
playing this game it's a dangerous game
to say the least
but guys get into the comments and tell
me what you're thinking do you actually
believe this Alliance would play such an
evil maniacal game with the writer's
Guild of America and actually do you
fear what might happen if the writer's
Guild of America do go on strike once
again because as I said last time we got
a load a load of reality TV shows
extended renewed or you know just
created to fill the gap
we're also going to be getting loads and
loads of uh repeats again and we all
know how we feel about too many of those
also
one more project on the pause do you
actually believe we're ever getting this
reimagined version of Babylon 5 or do
you think you know it's had its chance
we're 18 months down the line now JMS
it's probably not going to happen
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you're thinking
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
please go over to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you can see most
of our videos first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see it
without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]